while it's tempting to respond to the
input event inside of the event handler
it's generally considered bad practice
to do that now to get a better
understanding of that let's look at this
representation of a frame over time our
green boxes represent the update of
individual items that exist and the red
boxes represent the rendering of those
items now let's say for instance the
user hits their keyboard which would
move the player around and let's say
that our engine actually gets that
callback right here so our updating of
the player in a specific position has
already occurred including physics
engine processing and everything else
while our rendering will now be polling
data for a new position in the
environment now what this particular
instance can lead to is an interesting
phenomena this makes a disjoint
correlation between our update loop and
our render loop we can actually be
updating our environment with the player
at this position yet rendering with the
player at this new position now while
this may seem minut in a 30 frames or 60
frames per second environment things get
a little kooky once you start factoring
in networked physics which hopefully
we'll cover a little bit later in
practice the events come out a little
bit like this
so let's say we have a timeline of
events that are going to be passed into
our application and a timeline that
represents our update loop now what
occurs is that we're not really sure
when the events are gonna come to us
from the browser they can occur pretty
much anytime they want now what happens
is if we respond to them in turn we're
not going to have the ability for our
update system or rather our game code to
properly be able to react to them so
what we do is actually store the input
event data inside of our input manager
so that the update loop or game code can
query it whenever it wants